The wheels on the bus go round and round all through the town.
When we were younger, we were all nihilistic. We didn't care. Live for the day. Live fast.
I thought we were gonna change the world.
It's the trouble making that attracted me.
Drink beer and bash stuff up.
Punk rock was supposed to be about no responsibility, no rules. I'm gonna do things my way.
Maybe punk rock was never meant to grow up, but it did.
Having a baby changed everything.
I get up a lot earlier now.
I know you're tired.
No, I can't take 20 Barbies.
How about this one? This one's like cool, hearts and skulls.
It's tough to be a punk rock hero and to be a good authority figure for your kids.
Homework, bath, bed.
How am I supposed to shelter the "F" word?
The two dominatrixes on my arm, how do you explain that to a four-year-old?
No!
There's nothing really in the punk rock ethos that prepares you for being a dad.
My parents weren't really present.
Our dads weren't there, man.
Being gone all the time doesn't give you that bonding that you need.
How did we go from rebelling against our own parents and become parents ourselves?
The classic parent attitude with a kid like, "I brought you into this world, I gave you life".
It's like, I just think completely opposite.
My kids gave me life, you know, they gave me a reason.
That's what I wanna hold on to. It's that feeling that we can make a change out there...
...and maybe the way we change the world is by raising a better kid.
Sometimes you think about, "Oh, should I've tattooed my forehead." You know.